Hello everybody ! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to 'Getting Over It' with Bennet Foddy.
I've calmed down..
I've relaxed.
I've, gotten away from the game, and oddly enough,
When I stopped playing after I was so angry, I actually started playing again. Just very casually because..
This game is fascinating in that..
It makes me exceptionally angry, but you can see..
I'm back to where I once was. It makes me exceptionally angry, but at the same time..
Not really. (err) It's..it's
understandably like.. my fault.
I know.. I know I kept complaining about how the controls were all borked and all that stuff
But ee- it's understa-
EUUGH-- wooAAAAH
ugh..
It's understandably my fault.
That doesn't mean it's any less frustrating..
But I think like..
If there's any lesson to be learned about it, is like that's part of the experience.
It's what he's talking about..
As much as I still don't believe in the, the phyllis of all, philosophical
Yammer slammer of whatever.
woAAAAAAAH
welp.
oof apparently there's a way to get up there with that which I don't know how that would be true
I'm just trying it because why not what've I got better to do with my life than this... hup
Yep
Man that that's a doozy of an order okay. Let me try to do it then not that way because I'm a little bit
whuooo
ah very scary very scary don't do that ah
agh WAH
Jesus sure does like to swing swong me wherever the hell it likes to send me as well wherever I end up wha?
AAhhhh. ahhh.
Okay, I didn't get the shortcut in fact it might be better of me
just to like emphasize work on that particular whAAH
There we are
That particular shortcut because I am no better at getting this particular jump here
Than I am at that, but you know we'll see what happens
See what happens?
Okay, that's an option alrighty then
hm ouuuuu
Alright, I'll take it I'll take it I'll take that to the bank. I'll take that to the bank Wow
nOOOAHH
Swing swongin swings Wong and I don't like the swing swong
okay, back up here now a
Yi, how did I do this before I I remember the way I did way I did it was
I
Shot up bounced off this wall. No why hey, how's it going? Oh? Yeah?
Oh yah yah yah yah. Yah. Okay. You're just as frustrating
I don't know. Why but it's only when I decide to record it that it's frustrating me whoa
Whoa why how did you get under that I have no idea you sack of shit alright eh. Ya know
Close closer to the truth
Whoa did I lower my mouth? What what's going on the mouse sensitivity feels lower than it was before and I I don't remember
Wait that's not the normal
Wait is that that's not what that's not what it was right. That's not what it was right?
Okay, WHOA whoa?
Hey there sonny jim you cannot do that and that would be greatly appreciated
Yeah like that then drop here go up here whoa like this
Gentle as the summer mOON
Gentle as a butter flip okay
There we go
Go right here nestled in there see the problem is if you go straight up
You'll bounce but it you got to be a little bit out
oo ah
eEEH
Whoa whoa whoa that was a lot of SLIIIIDIIIING
Happening and I don't appreciate it
Wha-whoa I'm climbing like spider-man okay here we go no yes
Nope, nope okay up up
nope
Okay, see I've got better control of it. I'm getting better control anyway
Whoa whoa, whoa hey, I'm in here now, okay, that's a weird thing AH oh
Hey
stop being
super oh
No, that's super whA no NO no no
NONONO
GOD DAMNIT FUCKING HELL God. Damn it
REALLYYYY
God fucking damn it fuck you
Okay, I know I was moving around like a spastic monkey on LSD but that's not my fault
Whoa I'm up
No oh come on you dickbag oh
Really WHY why why why I will whoa AH AH
No what where am I oh my god. Oh?
*markipoo's mating call*
With all this like super movement what a try for this thing
Nope, no don't get on the thing oh
WHYy I can launch ten bajillion miles
No, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god that has just the perfect way of
Fucking you over
no, oh
God every time it's so fucking scary
Every god no. Oh
my god stop being dick
Look what oh okay? That's stuck maybe
Hmm there we go oh
Come on fucking hell
Why God why why'd you bounce?
Why did you just bounce? I'm not even talking about the camera balance
This is the proclivity as soon as you hit - just fucking nudge yourself off. Just the slightest bah
It's the slightest fucking thing
NO! NO. NO.
AAAAAAHHHH!
Oh my g- STOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOP!
Oh, my god
Jesus Jesus Christ, it's it's like I'm not doing anything more. It's the level of control
YOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOWWWWW!!!!
FUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK!!!
FUUUUUUUUCK!!!
*wings flapping*
God fucking damn it again? Really? Again? God damn, and I'm turning this sensitivity down
Oooohhh.
:O
Are you fucking kidding me? I will burn my own house down, you piece of shit and use your cauldron to put it out!
WOOOAAAAAA NOOOOOO!
Come on!
NOOOOOOOOOO!
You fucking piece of shit!
God dammit. God fucking damn it. I was doing
Beautifully. I was doing
wonder-fuck-ly. Oh God damn it! Jesus Christ!
What is happening to me? What is hap- What's happening to me?
Oh my god. Oh my god. I made this. It's fucking easy
Jesus Christ, I did this already
*get ready for the war cry*
AHHHHH!
Come o- WHAT WAS THAT?!
What the fuck was that?
Oh my god, yeah, I'll do it that way, but I I know it oh my god
What is going on with this fucking mouse?
I and yes, I'm blaming the mouse right now because the mouse is just being a fucking idiot.
The rules are...
If the rule- AAAAAAAAAAHHHHH!
WHAT THE FUCK??!
If the rules are si- OH MY GOD!
Just fucking GO!
And now I'm having trouble in the most basic shit!
It doesn't make any goddamn sense!
And I'm not- it's not like I'm taking it qui-
What is going on with my fucking MOUSE?!!!!
FUCK you!
Do you work still? Do you fucking work?
Oh, wow, it's still fucking works. Great.
Aw, I just spilled a FUCKING DRINK! God DAMMIT! FUCK ME!
I don't even know why I'm so mad
I don't even know why. I don't. I really don't know why.
I went into this episode. I was like alright. I got this it's gonna be fine
It's gonna be 100% chill shut up. I don't. I know.
ie
Well, this is this is an interesting deciSION
No, why did you just do that?
Please no god. Dammit. God fucking dammit. It was oh, whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa easy there. Ah?
God I was right there, how many times have I been right there nOOOO come on
Just cooperate no. Oh my god. Oh my god. What?
What are you doing? See see see. it's not me (x4)
It's me I know it's 100% me. I know the slightest breEEEEZE
That was going straight for death
No, oh come on th-fffffff fucking bounce
Jesus Christ, I just want to get back to where I was that's all I want I don't oh
I don't want anything else for Christmas. I just want to get back to where I was
And I can't get past this fucking part
No, every time. It's like 10, huh uh AH
NOOO GODDAMNIT WHAT THE
FUCKING FUCKING FUCKING FUCK
*mark rethinks his entire life*
It's so
Fucking stupid
And yes, I know there's speedrunners that can do it in a couple of minutes and like they make no mistakes going up
And yeah, they've probably been practicing for a long time, but if anything they could say that the,
oh God. Well that was that was
It's just the inconsistency like that's the only thing that I really don't like
Well oh well I
Kinda kinda a little bit well at least it bypassed a lot of bullshit
Let's see if I can stay up here, which I guess. I'm not gonna be able to that's my big prediction
Yep there we go that's my big whodda' thought my big prediction came true
Hey there we go whoa wait hang on no no no no I said there we go there we go
Okay, Wow I got it apparently
I think I think I know the trick to get up there now not really. It's not really a trick. It's just go launch yourself
Whoa big boy big boy with the big attitude
Whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy easy there. What was that jeezums
Ohhhhhhh
ohhhhhh
:O
I just learned a fundamental mechanic about this game. This is why it's inconsistent. I had no idea
*rethinks life again*
When you move the mouse it returns
*still in shock*
Holy shit
You guys don't understand how groundbreaking this is. Now I'm not saying that now that I know about this
I'm gonna be suddenly good
But this is the one thing of inconsistency that I was not getting
When I move the mouse you see the cursor it
returns
To the head of the hammer
That's what I was fighting
That's what my hand is trying to correct. That's why oh
Because I every time I land I'm trying to fight that movement
When it automatically returns to the center.
And that's why it follows the camera because if the position of the head moves,
That makes so much more sense now again. That's not gonna make everything suddenly hunky-dory
But it oh whoa it makes sense in my brain that if I don't wanna bounce
I just stop moving the mouse whereas before I was trauma
That makes so much more sense
Whoa whoa whoa
Yeah, hi yeah, okay, all right after a long arduous journey
I have returned to my home
Amongst the castles the the the the skyyyyyyyyy
Yi
Okay, all right somehow. I'm back here all right, so you need to go Mr. Orange
Excuse you. You could almost reach it right there, so it's not even that high up
But I got a swing out if I swing in, it's doom
Whoop
And there we have it okay, all right. Well. That's wonderful
Yay, I'm not celebrating because I know that I could
screw the ah screw this up at
aaaany mooooo
Moment
Okay. Alright. Gotta make a move here
ooo oooo oooo ah! noooooo NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO nooooooo oh no no no noooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
(r.i.p.)
Thank you everybody so much for watching
That's all the time I got for getting over right now
I've learned things but they don't help me. They do not help me. Nothing can help me
Nothing can help me. Nothing. Can help me
Let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always I'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
outtro
wow uhhh that was... um, something.. well.. go check out mark's channel if you are new. uhh, see you tomorrow everyone, bye for now.